hello the lottery game starts weekly
hang out every Tuesday 2 p.m. pacific
right here on video games calm and the
electronic triple is only seven days
away if you're watching last week's show
you'll know that we are counting down
our predictions for what all those
delicious conferences are going to be
showing us all next week we got through
for this for left to talk about so we
had to bring in the ringers from the UK
and a you to tell us old hot scoops
tamoor hussain what up Lucy James just
we've done thank you so much for coming
in first section we're talking about
Sony it's on to next Tuesday and 96 p.m.
pacific time here which is crazy o'clock
over in the UK i go stay up until 2am s
why we came here so i felt like okay we
got a big list of games to get through
first of all let's talk about first
party stuff that we know is definitely
definitely happening Lucy on charter for
excited finally no i mean like it got
pushed into next year so that means this
surely they must have something really
good for the c3 we obviously like that
was at 15 minutes saying of gameplay
they show a serious yeah something
substantial i liked it and you know it
was just it was so it was so uncharted
but it was just in this one freddie was
saying like it's more open now and as we
most ways to approach things like Oh
finally you know not just the one
determined path yeah so I'm really
excited about that I'm also very excited
to get just more nathan drake lots of us
guys doing that right yes howdy dog
something to care about well they went
from three to last of us yes oh you just
think about all the things they must
have learned making the last of us they
could bring into unchartered for ya
fingers crossed will see a big demo of
that s so that's the sort of the open
open end of the spectrum in terms of
gameplay design let's rain it back in a
little bit until dawn I've played a
little bit of this at the PlayStation
experience Jasper colonies yeah the OB
team wins are a bunch of this at this
Australian conference that no one will
know the name of what's called ebx oh
the Electronics Boutique oh they used to
have them in the UK and Ireland so it's
like Sydney last year
we saw a bunch of it so it's very off
like a big horror movie we've ECOD magic
well no I mean that's what they're going
for they're going for it's the movie
feel I mean you can see it it's it's
kind of everything that's mocked in my
cabin of the woods but take you
seriously yeah that day and that's the
experience they wanted to create for the
player so that's kind of what you've got
you've got the jump scares and the
wandering around a house and you're
carrying a torch is all very much what
you'd expect like multiple characters so
you're like you're the cheerleader and
the sort of jockey one and apparently
like entire characters can die
apparently they're going for a very like
replay value thing with this one yeah
you have to become too careful because
there is play a choice there and it's
kind of like if you don't want to screw
up and lose somebody forever yeah you to
be a little careful about the things
that you're going to do so you can
decide how to approach a situation
whether you want to like and like if a
guy's got you if he's caught you can
struggle to get free or you can try and
fight your way out of it you can choose
the shooter gun to pass by pressing X
square are talking about exact so that's
at this year it's one of the few games
that they'll probably be showing that
said this year so hopefully we'll see a
big chunk of that getting out two games
that we won't see ratchet and clank i
know there is a movie coming out next
year the game is also have a push till
next year you said Flair anymore people
still care about retching Clarice I
think they have a really strong since
Wow 2012 is into the Nexus stuff yeah
yeah I mean they had a bit of a decline
in terms of the health one they were as
kind of the developers of science and
look at other IPS I reckon they got a
bit bored or a chain clanks yeah I'm
excited to see whether they can kind of
rejuvenate the energy back into that
franchise it was always really really
creative with the weaponry and quite
charming the coat is really fun in it
like as much as you know take the mickey
boom but it actually works as an idea
for an animated movie hopefully that
that movie actually delivers on what the
game expenses but you know i'll give it
a good'n you want to show all right
again you really want our will be
excited for which my turn up at the Sun
Conference a scoop out of 5 Street fire
5 i'm like 99% sure that it's going to
be there yeah
we're going to be seeing I reckon we'll
get a good display of mechanics now
calculon's been quite kg in what they
show of it and I reckon they'll go into
a little more detail here and maybe
explain it it's you know it's a sony
only game not coming to xbox so i reckon
they will give it a good amount of time
and if i were a betting man I'd say
would see some new characters there so
yeah I'm really looking forward to it I
have played it a bit and it's like stop
videos about it up on site so you can
see that speaking of stony only games a
game that's been a sony exclusive as
much as it's been a game that we don't
know anything about it are we going to
see the Last Guardian at e3 2015 there's
so many rumors about it almost being
announced last year and then maybe just
disappearing when I can't gone yeah I
mean there was no no no it's called I
mean it's very it's still there it's
still think it's still a thing but
that's all we've heard it's still a
thing don't worry it's like is it the
big rumor mills that were going around
in the past month or so is fallout for
it to be a pre III teaser and then we'll
see a trailer and the other one that's
been going around is that last card is
going to be through this year and it
also might get a 2015 release date yeah
well you guys take it whether I I think
it's now or never for sony like are you
reaching you really really pushing it
now people are kind of reaching the end
of their tether with teasing and ya
still working here still work and you
can't say we're still working on it and
continue to show nothing because that's
pretty much like vaporware at that point
i remind that I feel like you can take a
really long time to make a game but
don't continue to tease it in the
meantime yes like I think if you want to
take 10 years to make a game take 10
years to make a game and then tell me
what it's coming out here before or the
year of don't continue to be like oh
yeah maybe this year maybe next year
maybe in five years so I think if it's
gonna be anything it's got to be you're
going to get it this year yeah early
next year otherwise don't do it and if
they really are working on it and nails
it when they're actually prepared Sony
did say by its owner calendar it's the
rest of 2015 is looking very very thin
from first part yeah
I mean the chances of lost Katya showing
up this year might be yeah even there is
a big gap that mean they could they
could spring also many games actually of
speaking of any games just thinking
about all the games they showed up last
year galaxy volume ABS ooh-wah term
might be shown there the tomorrow
children which has been playable at a
bunch of stuff and the witness might be
gunning release date rhyme everyone's
going to the rapture do you expect the
same sort of indie push this year as
well sony loves it Andy things I mean
they always dedicate a big chunk to
indie games which is what people love
about Sonja I think what people would
really like to see Microsoft perhaps do
a little bit more of have started to but
as far as the Sony games are coming up I
really like to look at that sooo yeah I
think it's lovely i like i like the
visuals I like the feeling and obviously
the the Jenny nostalgia it's interesting
there's so many of those indie games
have like sort of bulker door busted up
the the Playstations library while we're
waiting for all those big games to come
and moving back into the big games and
metal gear solid 5 grand zeros are
obviously gonna see you buddy we're
going to see a lot of it i think that
game to reach the stage where people
just want it now and it's difficult to
make a big splash with it at this point
I'm excited about him a huge metal gear
fan but I kind of just want it out i
think what we're gonna see is going to
be around the stuff that I mean previews
went up on on sites we've got paid up of
it Peter's got a great little a great
preview of it and I reckon the stuff
that he's talked about is what will get
to see in video form so ya reckon it's
gonna be exciting as good always to see
it at the drama around it as kind of
height in the yeah desire to see more
about it but yeah I think it's just like
just put it out now yeah give it to us
it's gonna well we're gonna get that in
the next couple of months as well
another game coming out this year
there's been a bunch of rumor and it's
not sure if you guys have been wise to
this but I've heard some little birdie
saying the black ops 3 might get that
Sony exclusivity yeah moving from like
yeah for like the early stuff not to be
a big guys right yeah they want to chase
it mmm I don't know like it's it's
obviously a big money maker but it just
seems like it feels like Activision's
trying to get their claws into someone
else that's willing to you know support
them fairly all along call of duty is on
the wane like whether you want to agree
with that or not
does like from the sales perspective was
its kind of dropping literally oh yeah
so but it's a good game for sony
regardless I mean DLC ourselves well
quality continues to do well and
compared to most other franchises out
there so yeah I think it's good I always
play ecology sometimes but gradually
it's kind of an obsession and any fans
of the god of war series sent on this
catch right now I enjoyed got a war to a
lot never got of war one a lot got a war
free was kind of like yeah you're
starting to lose it now and god of war
ascension was like what what you even do
ya the way what I'm getting at this
point I don't spend a while but I think
with the god of war three kind of
rounded off great oaks and most of Greek
mythology pretty well yeah maybe
something new forgot of war for the
summer and I mean they've is it's it's
hidden by like a lot of the side games
but there's actually a lot of law in the
first three games that hints at side
projects and there's like I think it's
got a war one or two where they actually
find a Pandora's box in in like a modern
era which is kind of an interesting
place to take it i mean Greek mythology
if you're going to reach read it the
best thing to do is kind of like mash up
with something new and fresh perspective
on it so like if they assassins created
it and put no elastic stuff no animus in
my Kratos okay so that's kind of a bunch
of games that we already know or if we
think my turn up and one of the
interesting things about saris
conferences that they got a lot of first
and second party studios connected to
them who are working on something we
don't know why and let's start with
Quantic Dream Lucy do you think we'll
see something this year from those crazy
cats and France if it's not an e3 it's
so gonna be at the PlayStation
experience because yeah waterlily what's
David cage been doing it's about time
cuz it's been a while since beyond now
yeah yeah I do yeah I kill me they have
been painted right now so yeah don't
damn occasion so you working on
something um I had that tech demo
remember what's the latest tech demo
alright yeah oh yeah those are dude and
inside
and that was the latest one all right
like is the new game gonna have anything
to do with that or is that just the
technology that they're gonna work into
it sometimes you've been hell right now
you're I like thematically it is
sometimes Rob up a little bit but never
the same exactly I would be surprised if
we don't hear something soon Quantic
Dream even even if it's just a rumble
like a like a brief mention oh and uh
Todd Connick jr. videos David K tioning
hi I'm Dave occasion that's it yeah I'm
making another game yeah i think i'm
still here stories i'm still trying to
make it work yeah yeah this is the car
one which ended up being beyond two
souls and we surprisingly there's a lot
of similarities to ex machina we just
came out oh yeah alex garland on ab your
commuting video wow yeah yeah she just
gets the pull and guerrilla games
killzone shadow fall came out at ps4
launch neither welcome all right those
guys must be working on some I'm sure
lens flare technology has they've gotta
be doing something with it yeah well
whatever they make is gonna look great
yeah that's good Jim I actually like
chatter for more than I like any other
Killzone game yeah but they sort of like
I guess I'm not a big cuz of funny
shadow fall wasn't wonderful it was one
of those Oh a first-person shooters out
on I launch console I guess yes against
the launch game passing over yeah kind
of in the same little round yet I keep
this game looked up see it doesn't
stunning yeah I think they do it's good
it's good like a press conference room
as well that's something yeah we've
kills on it's like you look at you
remember you're playing it and you kind
of like it was alright and then you look
any like but it does look good though
get sued over the graphics for the next
one god I forgot about a similar enough
sucker punch infamous was another big
sort of action game franchise which has
been successful for them do you think
we'll see something new into those guys
I don't think it would be another
infamous today yeah yeah just something
about a plate um second son yeah and
then he was first light as well and I
and I play them as I here all right but
just wasn't it didn't scream out for a
sequel it felt like self-contained yeah
I think they started when they dropped
coal and went on to a new character it
was kind of like yeah we'll try
something new and if it works really if
it's a resounding success yeah then it
you know it's worth pursuing but it was
kind of a bit tepid I enjoyed it I'm a
fan of the series but i'd rather see
Sucker Punch do something else like
they're really good at making platformer
games they may dislike also it's like
you know that they've got ideas for
something else and it would be good for
them to kind of break away it's almost
good that maybe in from the second son
wasn't a massive success and it kind of
the change their of phlegm do something
else and Media Molecule are French or a
company that we know really from one
franchise littlebigplanet and then tear
away has been doing wonderful game on
the playstation vita do you think i'll
see something new from then this year
head under I mean adjusted the little
extra tearaway so tearaway unfolded yes
so that wasn't too long ago sir I mean I
love to tear away yeah so they come out
with something like all B's pepped there
was news back in January that there were
they were going to announce their new
project some stage in 2015 and now
obviously as we can see from all your
answers coming out this week and last
week III is pretty busy when it comes to
my husband so maybe for a team like them
announcing their new IP doesn't work for
you three then again like they're
they're a company that Sony relies on to
kind of push their the technology that
people might not be too keen on with
some creativity and hot surfaces on
stage like my bet is like if you're
gonna kick anyone to to kind of show it
off you want Media Molecule because then
it kind of takes the this is just some
train that we're jumping on and we've
actually figured out something small
like interesting will they made the Vita
like all of a sudden ya know what all
those features its artwork for any other
game they're all amazing and tear away
if they could do that for more vr
something that is attractive for people
yeah they could like take take the VR
technology which is kind of like alien
to my lot of people and add some charm
into it I make you more like friendly
and a appealing to yeah you're right
because it is quite a scary prospect
let's talk about that for a second on
the hardware side project Morpheus
they've sort of been like they've been
playing it and teasing it and showing us
you know piecemeal at GDC here in San
Francisco they actually pushed it quite
hard I think everyone's pushing VR all
three of you going to talk you see first
of all do you think that they'll
actually show project Morpheus and what
do you think they need to show to like
really get people on board yes movie
it's probably different gonna be there
like especially with them with vows we
are making such a splash at the
beginning the year Sony probably gonna
show it just to be like we're still in
the game here yeah I think they've said
they're gonna I'm not a hundred percent
sure it's either III or gamescom but
they're saying they're gonna announce
the official release date and the
pricing of it at one of the two events
and yeah 5v5 well GL valve is not e3's
and they won't be showing you off but
obviously they've sent the the AVR
device to other developers or other
developers might have its own might take
it as an opportunity to kind of I mean
oculus is event is prior to e3 but you
know oculus is still like of all the VR
stuff it's the most threatening and yeah
overwhelming but some sunny could like
sneak in there and kind of capture this
is really studies opportunity to do a
big presentation from Orpheus it's a
really good time for it and the buzz has
been around for a while like they've
they've made a whole bunch of
announcements related to it it is a very
hard thing for them to try and demo on
stage is the thing that might get in the
way but I think anything right now like
cuz most people haven't had a chance to
put it the other device on their head
and because of the Sony name because
it's connected to the ps4 which
obviously has been selling really well
this would be a good opportunity to get
a leg up on on valve and stuff like that
anybody like okay well we have this easy
very accessible and from what I hit
quite comfortable yeah the I super light
yes sir I think that is gonna be the
main gym it'll be very interesting to
see the sony booth which is right behind
the game spa booth and this year to see
how many these demo stations they have
for Morpheus actually yeah like exactly
that what you said it's getting it on
people's heads is really the most I'm
really interested in seeing if they made
any significant changes to it yeah
because obviously valves the one is
getting a lot of press for being it'd be
kind of well your surroundings and
leaked ocular stuff leaked earlier today
like they've got a little controller
with it and some sort of base that keeps
track of you so learn a weird Apollo
lens stuff is starting to get good yeah
you're
enough it's unproven but it's different
enough to kind of demand its own
conversation separate from the other
guys okay we're gonna we've got a couple
of drags left on our list of all the
stuff that's happening at e3 I'm gonna
marry you no sir knees not going to I
love you so much but man they don't care
they don't care cosplay is the only
thing cross buying cross playing
everything the sona sona machine yeah I
play destiny on my toilet once I played
GTA on it watched as well for my bedroom
and it was ok terribly couldn't control
there's only not enough shoulder buttons
to do anything I was I had to touch the
reach-around tired or something I do
remember reading an article uh somewhere
of Sony predictions and it was like say
will mention the Vita twice and one will
be accidentally yeah all right three
things left in and I'll ask all three of
you one of them will we see one terabyte
PlayStation 4 Microsoft have announced
one today yeah I think Sony's made it
pretty easy to just upgrade on your own
and it's you know you can jam the solid
state hard drive in there I think Sony's
at that point where they're still
working on bundles like bundles are what
they're pushing the console with and
they're ahead of Microsoft at the moment
that's going to annoy somebody else so I
don't really have any incentive to kind
of yeah drop the price or create new
skus or that kind of thing and it's rare
like it's one of the first consoles I
thinks only kind of nailed first time
around they don't I guess they could
iterate on it again and create a slim
but they don't need to but they don't
really need to I reckon they could write
it out for a little while longer and if
you want to upgrade you can just do that
yourself that served as a guideline
which you couldn't put the xbox one and
Lucy power season two has been green
lace how many times only mentioned
powers at the Sony Prescott I can't wait
cuz that was the thing that last year I
mean that was the opportunity everyone
took to pee I took to the stage for
solid 10 minutes to talk about powers
and you know what I'm sure it's a great
TV show my guy is brian michael bendis
he's like one of the greatest comic
writers on the world and he's just like
yeah you could see these he was not
there like you don't need that much time
for TV show at a convention about video
games and you know what just just to
stick the knife in a bet we'll do it
again yeah orally
these were the knee with a new TV show
well I did I again powers was so great I
last one on the list here I've actually
got to grind through so i will probably
see something you kind of a sony press
conferences would actually digital and I
had for you just Vita how many times
will they say the word Vita during the
conference will keep a running total how
many times I'm gonna go right you don't
get it go oh look gotta go get up or
it's gonna fall into this is coming out
for cross play ps4 and Vita okay four
times F so if you want to tune into the
Sony conference will happen on gamespot
com Monday June fifteenth at 6pm pacific
time that's 2 a.m. if you're in the UK
and ireland and the last thing i have on
my list here is no man's sky I have it
from good authority they won't be on the
stage show so we'll have to see them
maybe off off to the side